how do you know you're real it's an
obvious question until you try to answer
it but let's take it seriously how do
you really know you exist in his
meditations on First Philosophy Rene
Descartes tried to answer that very
question demolishing all his
preconceived notions and opinions to
begin again from the foundations all his
knowledge had come from his sensory
perceptions of the world
same as you right you know you're
watching this video with your eyes
hearing it with your ears your senses
show you the world as it is
they aren't deceiving you but sometimes
they do you might mistake a person far
away for someone else or you're sure
you're about to catch a fly ball and it
hits the ground in front of you but come
on right here and now you know what's
right in front of you is real your eyes
your hands your body that's you only
crazy people would deny that and you
know you're not crazy
anyone who doubt that must be dreaming
oh no what if you're dreaming dreams
feel real
you can believe you're swimming flying
or fighting off monsters with your bare
hands when your real body is lying in
bed no no no when you're awake you know
you're awake ah but when you aren't you
don't know you aren't so you can't prove
you aren't dreaming maybe the body you
perceive yourself to have isn't we then
maybe all of reality even its abstract
concepts like time shape color and
number are false all just deceptions
concocted by an evil genius
no seriously Descartes asks if you can
disprove the idea that an evil genius
demon has tricked you into believing
reality is real perhaps this diabolical
deceiver has duped you the world your
perceptions of it your very body you
can't disprove that they're all just
made up and how could you exist without
them you couldn't so you don't life is
but a dream and i bet you arnt row row
row in the boat merrily at all are you
no you're rowing it wearily like a duped
non-existent doof you are slash art do
you find that convincing
you persuaded if you aren't good if you
are even better because by being
persuaded you would prove that you're a
persuaded being you can't be nothing if
you think you're something even if you
think that something is nothing because
no matter what you think you're a
thinking thing or as Descartes put it I
think therefore I am and so are you
really